Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
On est en 2012.
Je suis directrice de la qualité
et du développement durable
dans un grand groupe
de prêt-à-porter masculin
et je me retrouve à Paris en formation
sur la théorie U d’Otto Scharmer
pour m’aider à faire émerger
mon projet d’intrapreneuriat.
Et là, une formatrice
qui me connaît plutôt très bien,
et qui, accessoirement aujourd’hui fait
partie de notre comité stratégique,
me renvoie l’image qu’elle a
de moi à ce moment-là :
l’image d’une femme très engagée
autour du développement durable,
qui porte haut et fort ses convictions,
mais l’image
d’une femme seule sur son île déserte.
Bon, on est d’accord,
ça ne fait pas très envie.
L'image est assez forte,
elle me fait réfléchir.
Je suis en pleine réflexion
sur la création de ma business unit
au sein du groupe qui m’emploie
et je me dis : « Comment je vais réussir
à embarquer des gens sur mon projet
si je me retrouve toute seule
sur mon île déserte ? »
Et j’ai l’intime conviction à ce moment-là
que c’est en fédérant et en créant un
véritable écosystème que j’y parviendrai.
Aujourd’hui, presque dix ans plus tard,
j’ai la chance d’animer un écosystème avec
l’entièreté de nos parties prenantes :
nos partenaires fabricants,
nos partenaires revendeurs, nos clients,
mais également notre équipe,
nos actionnaires et nos confrères.
Il y a quelques semaines,
j’étais en formation -
j’ai eu la chance d’assister à la
présentation de deux chefs d’entreprise
qui m’ont partagé
leur stratégie de développement,
qui m’ont expliqué de façon très silotée
et très segmentée
la construction de leur organisation,
avec, d’un côté, leurs fournisseurs,
de l’autre, leurs concurrents.
Et les enjeux forts qu’ils avaient
autour de la croissance économique
de leur entreprise
et leurs difficultés
à conserver leur savoir-faire.
Là, je leur ai posé
une question toute simple :
« Mais pourquoi vous n’essayez pas
de travailler avec votre écosystème,
de construire quelque chose de plus
et de partager
pour développer [votre] entreprise ? »
Leur réponse, elle, est tombée
très, très vite, comme un couperet :
« C’est absolument impossible.
Notre secteur est ultra concurrentiel. »
OK.
Est-ce que la mode est
un secteur moins concurrentiel,
avec moins de secrets de fabrication
que le leur ?
Je ne répondrai pas à la question.
Je vous laisse juges de la réponse.
En préparant mon intervention de ce soir,
je me suis donc demandé finalement
quels étaient les facteurs clés de succès
qui nous avaient permis
de créer cet écosystème
et surtout, quels étaient leurs avantages.
Rétrospectivement, je vois
cinq facteurs clés de succès.
Le premier, c'est la co-construction.
On est en 2013 -
donc juste après ma formation -
j’ai la chance d’être détachée
en congé projet
pour réfléchir à la création
d’une offre « mode et responsable »
au sein du groupe qui m’emploie.
Je me retrouve seule dans mon bureau
et je dois écrire un business plan,
rédiger une plateforme de marque
et faire une étude de marché.
Ce que je ne vous ai pas partagé, c’est
que je suis ingénieur textile de formation
et une plateforme de marque,
à ce moment-là,
je ne sais absolument pas ce que c’est.
Donc, finalement, j’avais deux options
qui s’offraient à moi.
La première option : rester toute seule
dans mon petit bureau
et essayer de répondre
à toute cette liste de courses.
Et je ne savais pas très bien
par quel bout commencer.
Ou alors j’allais chercher au contraire
toute l’expertise
qui était dans l’entreprise
pour m’aider à corédiger mon business plan
et faire mon étude de marché.
C’est la deuxième solution
que j’ai adoptée.
Et, quelques mois plus tard,
quand le comité de direction
a validé la création du projet,
je ne me suis pas retrouvée seule.
Tout de suite, ça a été facile d’embarquer
les hommes et les femmes
qui avaient déjà participé
à cette co-construction.
Le deuxième facteur de succès,
c’est une rencontre individuelle,
privilégiée et personnalisée.
Je connais par exemple le prénom
de tous mes partenaires fabricants.
Vous pourriez me dire : « C’est simple,
c’est toi qui es allée les chercher. »
Pour autant,
si je devais faire un parallèle,
c’est un peu comme quand vous recrutez
un collaborateur dans votre entreprise.
Moi, on m’a appris à faire une liste
des compétences incontournables
dont vous avez besoin
pour recruter votre collaborateur
de façon à le mettre en succès
dans sa mission.
Quand vous recrutez quelqu’un
dans votre écosystème,
c'est à peu près la même chose.
Chez nous, par exemple,
c’est la proximité.
Parce qu’on considère que,
sans la proximité,
on ne créera pas forcément
les conditions de la confiance.
J’ai interrogé en préparant
mon intervention de ce soir
un partenaire fabricant, accessoirement
un de nos plus gros filateurs
et aussi un de nos actionnaires -
il a fini par monter au capital quelques
années après la création du projet.
Je lui ai dit : « Gilles, qu’est-ce qui a
fait que vous êtes rentré dans l’aventure
et que vous avez construit
une partie de l’histoire avec nous ? »
Il m’a répondu : « Christèle, vous
connaissez Montaigne et La Boétie ?
- Heu... oui.
- Eh bien, parce que c’était lui,
parce que c’était moi. »
Cette création de relation
unique et privilégiée
a fait qu’effectivement, on a créé
la confiance pour aller un pas plus loin
et construire un futur ensemble.
Le troisième facteur clé de succès,
c’est ce que j’appellerais
la vision partagée,
une espèce de cohérence
entre le fond et la forme.
C’est quand-même plus simple
de s’embarquer dans un projet
dès lors qu’on partage
un socle de valeurs communes
et qu’on sait où on veut aller.
On est d’accord,
moi, mon job, c’est d’écrire la vision,
ou de la coécrire,
ensuite, de la partager avec beaucoup
d’enthousiasme et d’énergie.
Parce que finalement,
quand la cible est éclairée,
on peut se mettre en route plus facilement
pour atteindre la bonne cible.
Le quatrième facteur,
c’est ce que j’appellerais
la confiance réciproque.
Depuis le début de l’histoire,
on n’a jamais créé une relation classique
entre un fournisseur et un client.
On aurait pu, par exemple,
quand on a des problèmes de production,
appliquer des pénalités de non-qualité
ou des pénalités de retard
quand nos fournisseurs sont en retard,
Mais finalement, en y réfléchissant,
on aurait pu mettre en péril
tout l'écosystème.
On aurait pu faire déposer
le bilan à certains
et donc, du coup, mettre en difficulté
la chaîne de fabrication
et, par voie de conséquence,
nous-mêmes, notre entreprise.
Le dernier facteur clé,
c’est une réflexion en écosystème
et plus en silos.
Quand on vient de la distrib, je peux vous
dire que ce n’est clairement pas gagné.
Dès le début,
on a pris le parti de mettre l’ensemble
de nos parties prenantes ensemble
pour leur apprendre à se faire connaître,
à se connaître
pour qu’ils puissent travailler ensemble
derrière et nous faire gagner du temps.
Certes, on était
une petite équipe à l’époque.
Bon, OK, on est toujours une petite équipe
aujourd'hui, mais le but derrière,
c’était de pouvoir se dire :
« Si on leur apprenait à se connaître,
ils allaient essayer de résoudre
des problématiques
sans avoir à passer par nous,
et on allait pouvoir gagner du temps. »
Le pari, on l’a gagné.
Et si on prend encore un peu plus
de hauteur et si on réfléchit plus large,
on peut inclure nos concurrents,
ceux que, nous, on appelle nos confrères
dans cet écosystème.
Qui a déjà dans la salle travaillé
avec son concurrent direct ?
Nous, notre principe, c’est :
on a tout intérêt à chasser en meute
plutôt que de chasser séparément.
Donc on veille à ne pas marcher sur
les plates-bandes des uns et des autres.
Ce n’est pas
qu’on ne développe pas des produits
dans le savoir-faire de la marque
qui est à côté,
mais on les développe ensemble,
et ça nous permet d’être malins
et beaucoup plus agiles.
J’imagine qu’il y a plein de pragmatiques
dans la salle - je me trompe ?
J’ai toujours dit :
« On réussira ensemble
ou on se plantera ensemble. »
En 2018, coup de tonnerre :
on quitte le groupe
qui nous a incubés pendant cinq ans.
Moi, de façon très personnelle,
j’avais passé cinq ans de ma vie
à dire que j’étais intrapreneuse
et surtout pas entrepreneuse.
Donc j’ai déjà dû me poser la question
« J’y vais, j’y vais pas ? »
Vous vous doutez bien que si je suis
ici ce soir, c’est que j’y suis allée.
Mais pour autant,
à ce moment-là de l’histoire,
est-ce que j’allais à nouveau,
comme cinq ans avant,
me retrouver toute seule
sur mon île déserte ?
Ou alors, est-ce que j’avais
vraiment réussi à fédérer
un écosystème derrière moi
qui allait suivre ?
L'écosystème a suivi.
Tout d’abord, mon équipe a suivi,
et ça, ça a été un signal hyper fort.
J’avais confiance dans mon projet,
mais finalement, je n’étais pas la seule.
Et tous nos partenaires fabricants
ont également suivi.
Je peux dire que ce n’était pas gagné
car quitter le groupe
qui nous avait incubés,
pour certains, ils ont vu
leur volume divisé par 10.
On est d’accord,
ce n’est pas le monde des Bisounours.
Certains ont changé leurs conditions,
mais un, tous ne l’ont pas fait,
et deux,
ceux qui l’ont fait nous ont
quand-même laissé le temps
de nous remettre en phase
de croissance pour le faire.
J’ai eu Laurent, notre tricoteur,
au téléphone
et il m’a dit : « Christèle,
en tant que chef d’entreprise,
j’ai passé ma vie à prendre
des risques en misant sur des personnes.
Parce que quand on aime quelqu’un,
on irait avec lui au bout du monde. »
Et donc, le fait d’avoir créé
cette relation unique et privilégiée,
d’avoir partagé une vision commune,
d’avoir collaboré avec eux,
ça a fait qu’on a surmonté
les épreuves ensemble
et qu’on continuera à surmonter
les épreuves d’après.
Pour conclure, ce soir,
après avoir partagé mon expérience,
si vous voulez miser sur un écosystème,
j’aurai trois questions à vous partager.
La première question, c’est : « Qui vous
voulez embarquer dans votre écosystème ? »
Tout le monde ne peut pas venir
dans votre écosystème.
La deuxième question, c’est :
« Qu’est-ce que votre écosystème
va vous apporter ? »
Je vous le dis tout de suite,
la réponse, ce n’est pas « du chiffre
d’affaires » ; ça, c’est la conséquence.
Et la dernière question, qui me semble
être pour moi la plus importante, c’est :
« Qu’est-ce que vous vous pouvez
apporter à votre écosystème ? »
Après mon intervention de ce soir,
si j’ai un vœu à formuler,
ce serait de recroiser
ces deux chefs d’entreprise
et qu’ils me disent :
« Christèle ! C’est génial !
On a finalement échangé
au sein de notre écosystème.
On a développé un nouveau produit
et on est en super croissance. »
Merci à tous !
(Applaudissements)